[Music]
thank you for visiting
dare to know chess in the age of reason
one of our summer exhibitions here at
the world chess hall of fame
the show is inspired by chess in the age
of enlightenment
and particularly how chess was part of
a really lively scene of thinkers
writers philosophers
who are all passionate about the game of
chess chess had a really special part in
coffee house culture and coffee houses
were where people would go
either to play chess read discuss with
others the kind of events of the day
kind of the beginning of the public
sphere in this case
we have artifacts related to the cafe de
la rechans and in the center
is a really beautiful chess set called
the region's chess set
after the cafe the cafe de la regence
was the most famous
chess coffee house in paris in the 18th
century
and we have books by some of the writers
and chess players who are associated
with the lively chess scene there
we also have this print which shows
people huddled around a chess board
eagerly watching the next move of the
game as some of the early stars of chess
are playing including philidor who is
not only a chess player but he is also a
composer
and his portrait is on the opera in
paris
we have this case which shows not only a
mysterious
musical chess set at the end but also
other games that were played at the time
including
this beautiful tarot card set
many of the artifacts in this collection
or in this exhibition are from the
collection of tom gallegos
and he's a collector of antique games as
well as chess sets
we also have this freemasons apron
and if you look carefully at the floor
it has a chess board pattern
familiar black and white squares
this is a really special highlight of
dare to know
it's a chess head that once belonged to
madame tussaud
and we have a letter on display from her
grandson
attesting to its um provenance as her
own set
ma'am to soda is best known today for
her wax museum in london but she lived
many years in paris where she was
associated with royalty
and then when the french revolution
happened
her own life was in danger but she
ultimately
was saved and then she had the kind of
gruesome job of
cataloging the faces of many of her
friends who were sent to execution she
left france later and settled in london
where she rose to fame as the
proprietors
of the wax museum
the mechanical turk or the chess
automaton was a famous illusion
from the enlightenment era and it was
presented as though it were a chess
playing robot when in reality there was
a person
inside the cabinet controlling the moves
of the chessboard
people were allowed to challenge the
turk
and you can see in this little
reproduction
they would open the cabinet doors at the
beginning almost like um
you know a magic trick where the
magician's going to cut saw a woman in
half and they throw up in the cabinet
and they say nothing underneath nothing
under here
and then they close everything up and he
would
play against dignitaries
people in royal courts he traveled
throughout europe
and then ultimately to the united states
and captured the imagination of people
around the world and writers would
kind of challenge themselves to try to
figure out what was really going on
with the mechanical turk so you can see
in these illustrations
some different ways that people thought
that someone was hiding in the cabinet
including that someone was inside this
representation of the mechanical turk
himself
almost like a costume moving the arms
as you know the game would progress
and we'll finish here with the
encyclopedia chess set
the encyclopedia was a really unique
project which encapsulated the goals of
the enlightenment era
and in it the authors sought to catalog
all of the information in the world a
very humble aim
and so it was everything from the newest
political ideas to
articles about different professions and
in this case
this chess set is inspired by an article
from about toy makers
in france tableteers and so this is a
pattern that shows
a really common style of chess set at
the time
represented in the show by this one
and so it kind of like became associated
with the encyclopedia
which was written by denise detero and
his collaborators
he and his collaborators were
often subject to persecution
for their ideas and sometimes had to go
into hiding
and so this chessa even though it looks
pretty humble has a really important
place in history
thank you for visiting our virtual
version of dare to know chess in the age
of reason
and i hope that we'll be able to see you
in st louis soon at one of our
exhibitions